one of the nice things about nation is
that we can exercise some volition over
what a country is what it stands for
and what it means to us and I'm more
interested in the aspects of of identity
and of self that we can
change and mold because I think of self
not as a static thing the whole idea of
self that we're now raised with is
you're already pre-made and the project
is to recognize what you are already and
that is not my experience of being a
person my experience I don't want to go
to New Age on you but it's a continual
Act of becoming of of creation and
that's a much more Dynamic idea of what
it means to be a human being to focus
instead on the things that are never
going to change from the day you're born
is like locking yourself in a room yeah